question number three final question
does jesus understand relationships
between
boys and girls
or a boy-girl relationship since he was
never in one
and the
question is
has his lower nature been tempted like
ours
uh hebrews chapter 4 verse 15
we have not an high priest which cannot
be touched with the feeling of our
infirmities but was in what
come on say it loudly
all points
now god's word must be believed
that's all how do i believe it i believe
it and i submit myself to it he was in
all points tempted like as we are jesus
did not have to have a girlfriend
boyfriend relationship to understand the
struggles that are inherent in that kind
of relationship he
understands do not limit the ability of
jesus christ i've said before it makes
no difference what your struggle is
jesus christ understands precisely and
even more clearly than you and i
understand our struggles because he
overcame them
and so whatever it is you trust jesus
christ yes he was tempted in his lower
nature
that's where we're usually tempted
whether it's appetite that's the lower
nature
sexual desires that's the lower nature
but they were put in us by god yes he
was tempted there because he was tempted
in all points
but he never sinned because his higher
faculties his will
was under the constant unbroken
uninterrupted control of his father
that's the secret
who has your will and who has mine the
power that part of the brain that
office where decisions are made
regarding you
who controls that if it is the spirit of
god that power will control the lower
nature
so jesus was tempted yes
but his will was always in the control
of the father and by that constant
supply of power he never fell and the
same experience can be ours we can come
to the place my beloved brothers and
sisters where we
absolutely
hate sin of every size
thank you brother jason
god bless you